un hommage aux hommes et aux femmes en
uniforme venus défendre la démocratie et
les remerciements des élus reconnaissant
un événement matinale hors de
l'ordinaire pour une journée historique
un vote de mise en accusation du
président qui se tient sur les lieux du
crime
1 capitole transformée en camp retranché
c'est la deuxième fois en à peine plus
d'un an que la présidente de la chambre
des représentants demande la destitution
de dow jones
aux yeux de nancy pelosi c'est clair le
président a incité une insurrection une
rébellion armée
il représente un danger réel et immédiat
et doit partir et macao
qu'ils soient de gauche ou de droite les
représentants dénoncent ton coeur
l'assaut de la semaine dernière prosper
le chef des républicains va même jusqu'à
tenir dans notre chambre responsables
des violences
mais là s'arrête l'unanimité essayez de
le destituer si rapidement serait selon
kevin mercredi une erreur une nouvelle
cause de division dans un pays déjà
déchiré
une division qui apparaît maintenant au
grand jour au sein même des rangs
républicains
artix alors que ce représentant de
l'ohio récemment médaillés part dans nos
chambres dénoncent un procès politique
celui-ci de l'état de washington
considère les actions du président comme
inexcusable et annonce voter pour sa
mise en accusation à wow tu y as
une procédure expresse bouclé en moins
d'une journée et un vote sans appel 2
132 voix pour 197 contre dix élus
républicains ont voté contre le
président du jamais vu la preuve selon
nancy pelosi que personne n'est
au-dessus de la loi
pas même le président président de plus
en plus isolé qui lance un appel au
calme et à l'unité dans une vidéo mise
en ligne après le vol un message qui
tranche avec ses déclarations
belliqueuses de la semaine dernière
preuve que la menace d'une destitution
est prise très au sérieux à la vie
d'enfants drakkar la deuxième manche de
cette procédure à l'encontre de damas
comme le procès lui-même veut maintenant
se dérouler au sénat de toute évidence
après la fin de son mandat l'événement
potentiellement lourde de conséquences
déjà passée à l'histoire pour avoir été
deux fois mise en accusation dans notre
champ pourrait devenir le premier
président trouvé coupable est destitué
ce qui mettrait un terme définitif à sa
carrière politique
ici jean françois bélanger radio canada